Oh my gosh.
Where do I even begin?
From one to ten, my stress level is at about a six.
My stress level today is probably in between a seven and an eight.
All I wanna do is relax.
I just don't know how.
Welcome to this guided meditation.
Are you ready?
Let's begin.
Find a comfortable position.
Close your eyes.
Take a deep breath in,...
...and as you exhale, let your body begin to relax.
Listen to the gentle purring of the happy kitten.
Purr.
Now, open your eyes.
You can't be stressed after sitting in a box full of kittens.
Being around young creatures just reminds you to take it easy.
It was great!
Unexpected and adorable.
You wanna do it again?
Yeah.
Right now?